elon's making terminators that's right
did you notice that that robot that
they're making is five foot eight which
i think is a perfectly average height
yeah i mean someone would say that five
foot seven is even more average yeah
right yeah five foot eight above average
as well someone said yeah i would say
the same thing too yeah you guys done
have you done the the studies on this
the surveys have you right there
there's a lot of wikipedia articles out
there
by country
that's fast let me tell you in some
countries
i'm way above average height average
male height usa somebody who's six foot
nine no okay so average male height in
the us is five foot nine
that's a lot no that's not good that i
mean what when was that from the yeah
what year was that what are your twenty
eight also are they
are they dividing this up by race 2018 a
lot of things change a lot a lot of
things some countries in europe just
have a lot of tall people well
but it's in the us though
but like they immigrated here oh i see
it screwed up the average i go you see
i'm saying it's the white's fault it
sounds like a very inspiring article so
it says average for
hispanic in the us is five foot seven
um black is five foot nine god damn it
[Laughter]
you don't you don't make it anywhere
buddy i'm sorry
oh jason says jesus was also five eight
oh i'm in
jesus was five eight the lord type
or jesus
i think jesus also five eight really
maybe
somewhere around that range yeah
i'm five foot ten
um it goes all right i can reach like
most high shelves
connie does give off short king energy
he really does give off short king
energy yeah yeah yeah he is five eight
that's not that short though which isn't
which is an average height which is an
average height yeah how tall is kim
kardashian she's probably super short
and maybe right can get probably but she
gives off tall girl aaron
she gives us very tall and it's 6.5 11
i'd believe it
yeah i reckon she's probably like
five seven five five five oh my god
player could have been oh my god bless
is alone oh i'm getting are you okay oh
no oh oh no what can i say
the ladies love me
they were like oh my god he's at least
five foot
five what the [ __ ] is up oh big good
lady
all right
you know they seem like they're a lot uh
a lot more lethal in the films
they're uh
yeah and the films they're like one of
them maybe ripley is like that's like
the
there you go all right big mama dead
god what was awesome when are we doing
he was like
he was composed this is the last
soundtrack he's ever gonna do yeah he's
out here with his bongo drums oh god
look at the camera there's another one
oh [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] i just watched
kevin get [ __ ] slapped
right in his face
look at the little feet they're kind of
cute you know
i feel like if they made cuter sounds
they'd be way cuter yeah just kind of
walk along like yeah like little iguanas
chilling off pudding like
like that sort of [ __ ] yes
my ex-boyfriend always says yeah oh oh
oh got my first little bit of lag
yeah somebody mad i think it's a spitter
oh
oh
oh that's an actual xenoblock that's a
whole ass animal oh she is getting
melted though oh [ __ ]
oh wait that was she [ __ ] slapped the
turret oh
she was at least six foot you guys yeah
oh my god queen
whoa they're definitely way above
average kim kardashian way above average
yeah freaked like
she's the height of kim kardashian's
energy all right healing we have not
been using it we're gonna do this
oh they're all just oh my god they got a
family
that's a whole ass family they got the
best family over here
man he must have a stream for very long
[ __ ]
we got
how's the game so far we're having a
good time i'm enjoying it this is
actually pretty fun yeah and it's right
and it runs well when it's running yeah
it runs great it looks good
good sound design it's pretty basic i'm
gonna put one down behind right here
yeah let me do one right here there you
go
okay um i have another one oh in the
corner right here there's a nice little
spot right here let's do
this way the nice little spot did you
put one all the way up here i put one
right here on my ping okay i'm going to
put this here oh where and then
i have static grids as well so let's
throw one of those down i have an extra
tour but i want to
do you have incendiary rounds also
yeah i do okay cool
the pistol's actually not that bad i'm
rocking austin wintery goes hard this is
like
the the
slipknot of uh
horror games definitely this is
definitely one of those ones where
he submitted it to the devs and they
called him back and they're like and
they were like sure bro this slaps oh my
god like you sure bro like you don't
want to hold this for the next god of
war
is this why you want to blow this all
right
right now on aliens sure
like you know we're not going for a 10
in this game right like we're trying to
release a solid 70. yeah we're after a
good seven uh 3d audio in the music too
gross spitter oh behind us yeah well
don't kick shame annie some people have
different preferences
turrets are kind of doing
yeah they are doing the lord's work yeah
i'm surprised that they haven't feel
like i'm not doing much right now
honestly yeah i was going to say blessed
but i'm glad that you
addressed it so we didn't have to
oh hey that's what i'm here for
whole [ __ ]
transplant
oh my god shoot the tolls
you're crazy you're crazy
yeah blessing i'm gonna be honest it
looks bad from this perspective i don't
know that you should be doing that i was
going good for a second and then they
they realized my plan okay we did the
thing by the sounds of it
i'm holding ass
i'm in here wait where are you going
where are you going we're in the
elevator you see the [ __ ] oh my god the
objective you dumb [ __ ]
the amount of aliens that were out there
[Music]
what should i do vulnerability
assessment drone that's stupid but fine
i guess i really feel like i should have
gone to buy one of the turrets whatever
i'm not you still don't have any cards
do you oh hi
my cards all suck so bug stomper is
pretty neat we have to just do a [ __ ]
ton of head shots
and there's like
repercussions yeah that's easy yeah
let's do it
we don't get any more points for it
though or we do uh we get 1.75 huh oh no
you'll have to go through the network
yeah we know all about the network
security room
troy baker i've done this before no cry
about it scared voice all right yeah
um i have somebody named lawson in my
chat asking andy can you ask alana what
chip she's eating i have to wait 30
minutes to ask her
that's called gone rogue
gone rogue yeah the brand is called gone
rug
they are [ __ ] delicious sounds like a
like an indie it's so much protein game
publisher no i think it's like i think
that the branding is trying to convince
men that they should like take them
camping or something like that i mean
it's basically jerky it's just dried
chicken but flavored with teriyaki
that's why i'm saying it's like it's so
much protein god i'm so hungry
sorry about that i'm gonna feast after
this i was actually thinking i haven't
been to a 7-eleven
since the pandemic started i've not been
to just like a corner store
the whole time yeah i've been to 7-11 so
much love some snacks i love the
mechanics and traditions of going to a
corner yeah good mechanics
which is oh [ __ ] you oh i thought that
was blessing and it was actually aliens
i'm crazy out here i'm
crazy you're [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] crazy dude
all right austin okay austin calm the
[ __ ] down boston wintery damn [ __ ]
you know that you know the rules i i
guess i i i did know that
you're right
must have overlooked the training
i'm sorry apologies captain no okay andy
i get that you're constantly trying to
audition to be in the next god of war
but i'm not having it okay
joke's on you
is it though
i feel like i would know about that
chris judge told me it heard me and he
was like wow you know i gotta dude's
[ __ ] got it man you got it do i
really do that
i need to step down man
i don't got it anymore yeah there are a
bunch of people at the studio
pretty frequently play golf with him
so i am out here actively trying to
learn to play golf just so that i can
play golf with christopher dude that
would be awesome i love golf by the way
and by me just i mean not even if chris
judge there i feel like that would maybe
be weird for you and chris after you
know you stole his role i just feel like
i mean it was it was very much like a he
voluntary and he vomited
okay yeah but then if you beat him in
golf like i just feel like it you know
it's a bit more there's no shot i'm out
driving that dude no he's apparently
very good yeah i'm i really enjoy golf
too actually but um
it seems like a thing that to get better
at it you have to play it like four
[ __ ] times a week yeah yeah i ain't
got that kind of time we got to the golf
course uh at near austin community
college and we had a discount so we were
golfing for eight bucks instead of like
the usual four yeah whatever
ev every time it was a yeah
we had a student discount god damn
oh my
holy [ __ ] man
dude this shotgun is awful it's a it's
such a blessing that this game actually
runs good because it would feel so bad
if it didn't i mean doesn't that apply
to all the games
yeah but like this game would be 20 this
game is fun because it runs as well as
it does you know like
it is really fast in the way that
whenever you play like a mario game
you're like or you're playing mario damn
this [ __ ] dude jump good god the frame
rate is so [ __ ] on when you're playing
multiplayer
yeah well i mean we still all played a
lot of animal crossing even though that
that game is garbage
sure yeah
[ __ ] off dude
let me slap you
[ __ ] oh i killed that that that no i'm
not trying to emote right now carriage
is doing the fortnite dance try i'm not
trying to
i just killed a xenomorph by kicking it
in the face
oh spitty spitty [ __ ] yeah they put the
spit right next to the ammo refill
yeah it's crafty
yeah that's [ __ ] where's the honor in
that you know i did that [ __ ] on purpose
yeah
i got a daily opportunity complete oh
baby look at me baby we're feeling good
all right okay are there are there more
med kids here or are we out
he might be out there's only there's
always three
oh really yeah
what the [ __ ]
wow andy you took two that's wild
i took one what the [ __ ]
everybody knows that you did it that's
what you know that's what we decided so
like i knew you're down to do some shady
[ __ ] andy but that's i don't know about
that
on another level
well i mean you want your best player
like was it you though blessing did you
do it i might have did it on accident
[Laughter]
[Music]
it sounds that way is this the [ __ ] up
room no this is not yet foxbot oh big
[ __ ]
no i'm not press a instead of s
ah
i threw my grenade right at her
um okay getting blessed up
yeah yeah go for it i got oh my god i'm
trying thank you no i'm getting slopped
about andy you got to do better defense
than that
oh where are you oh behind you
you said that as i was backing into the
acid
oh i didn't get anybody with that are
you kidding me
i'm just shooting at bodies as they're
as they're dead i really need to up
these reflexes
be like oh shoot the oh it's dead alana
keep in mind you gotta feel you drop
that [ __ ] when we're sick of it i will
do it when we're all looking a bit
[ __ ] up you may want to take your heel
now bless yeah that's a good call oh
she's here oh she's here
get out of there
come at me monica monica
oh she just threw my turret away she
[ __ ] came at you dude i don't know
what you wanted
oh she left
andy what what horn is that deep horn
that came in a few seconds ago the one
to the deep
that's the one
like like the tuba is as deep as you can
get maybe like a baritone or bare tone
i don't i don't i don't know actually i
feel like i'm really fine
french horns are pretty deep [ __ ] you
know about horns how did you know to ask
andy about horns is this some like
untapped wealth of knowledge andy has
that i didn't know about i wasn't banned
as a musician are you a horn girl i was
in band i didn't know you're a man i was
a perk i was a percussionist but i nice
and do you know the song blood on the
leaves by kanye
what kind of horn is that is what
it's like there's a specific kind of
horn i have in my head like the bomb
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna save the
i'm gonna save one of these [ __ ]
ready then yeah i'm ready to roll all
right i was born ready let's do it
aliens aliens ain't got [ __ ] on me all
right
dude that spitter got [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
you got [ __ ] destroyed you thought
you could walk into my house
[Music]
hell nah
monica's back
he's back baby
come on there's no way she even made it
back with her did she leave
yeah she pissed out again but she was
the turrets were [ __ ] her up she was
i thought that she had some kind of
electric ability until i realized it was
the turrets that have done it to her oh
she's here she's she's she's i'm
oh she's dead
so fast she came back with like
i don't even know if we need uh need to
use the health darts yeah i just put on
i put down another turret just in case
because why not because
the ggs are super easy yeah that was
amazing that was a piece of cake that
was dope as [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hey
here's the good actor
yeah i did act as a little hot out you
guys are here that's him
oh he's cuter than i expected
unbelievable he looks like a young
indiana jones glasses yeah damn
hey good job all right
look at it looks like it looks like it
was a tuba yeah we're all really proud
of kevin he finally accomplished
something my gosh
how do i keep getting so many assists i
get the least kills but the most
assistant oh it's probably because my
weapon doesn't have a uh a lot of damage
output
oh that's a good point i think the fact
that you're using a submachine gun we
have finishing power with our yeah it's
true it's true i'm just like one tap in
fools i'm just one tap yeah
just one time
that was fun as [ __ ] it was good
yeah good time good time